move over Walter white we found someone
who uses the word family more than you
do and it is that guy seriously new
drinking game got to take a drink every
time Vin Diesel in this movie says the
word family you'll be trashed actually
baffling says it a lot
Furious 7 so Furious 7 is the seventh
Fast & Furious movie this movie
incorporates a lot of things that people
liked about the franchise before and it
takes the franchise in the new direction
the franchise is going at first it shows
this drag race it's the same kind of
race as they did in the first movies Oh
throwback then Jason Statham hits the
scene he's the brother of Dracula untold
from the last movie he wants revenge so
he starts coming after the crew which is
a cog in this movie but ultimately the
government's like hey you got to help us
you get this device that they call it
the gods eye or it's just gods I know
though it's like the difference between
Facebook and the Facebook I don't one of
them so they're trying to go after that
thing and then Statham is coming after
them and they want to go after
Stateville Statham's kind of like the
Winter Soldier minus the fact that he
was ever good ever he shows up to cause
problems while the bigger things in the
movie are happening while you're
suspending your disbelief to watch this
movie because you really have to from
the beginning he shows Jason Statham
throws down with the rock pretty near
the beginning of this movie the rock
straight up just uppercuts and Statham
gets up from that keeps fighting right
there I was like I don't think this
movie's gonna be realistic I just don't
think so at all which is pretty good so
now you're prepared for it because
everything else happens in this movies
just dope doesn't make sense the good
thing is this movie knows that this
movie knows it doesn't make sense it
knows that people are there just to kick
their feet up and have a good time it's
not there to be the most realistic movie
in a franchise that springboarded off
the premise of Point Break with cars
no I started be a popcorn flick for you
to have a good time and it does that
really well does it do it great not
always every time something crazy
happened in this movie I step back and I
was like that's not [ __ ] possible
well simultaneously I step to the side
and I was like yeah but that's pretty
[ __ ] cool I mean holy [ __ ] the
one-liners in this movie hola this movie
is complete in 90s action movie that's
what it is not just because of the
action but the dialogue that this movie
was in the 90s where it belongs Arnold
Schwarzenegger to be in this I know that
because this movie has all the Arnold
one-liners you could ever think of
without Arnold Schwarzenegger actually
saying them I will say this movie is the
best videogame movie ever made on the
premise that the last act of this movie
is straight-up twisted metal it's that
kind of Anarchy is that kind of chaos in
the end guys Furious 7 does exactly what
it wanted to do it entertains you it
gives you absurdity it knows it's crazy
it gives you all the one-liners you
could possibly want
a lot that you probably don't everyone
has a great time in the movie the movies
predictable as [ __ ] in the end I was
glad this is to send off Paul Walker
gets and not brick mansions that would
have been sad but they came through in
Furious 7 and it was actually a good
time in fact it was a good time no
alcohol required just don't do that
drinking game I suggested in the
beginning of this video
she'll die you just straight-up will die
alright guys so Furious 7 have you seen
it what did you think about it what is
your favorite movie in the Fast &
Furious franchise mine was Fast Five
that was one where I was like Oh Lee
[ __ ] we're doing other things now so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more